The most famous news story of all time unfolded
behind me, the headquarters of the Washington
Post.
The story was the Watergate scandal, and the
Post reporting on it helped bring down a president.
The story began when five men were caught
burglarizing the Democratic National headquarters
in the Watergate complex.
As it happened, they had links to President
Nixon's reelection campaign.
Their capture sparked a flurry of news coverage,
but then it quickly died down.
Five months later, Richard Nixon was elected
to the presidency by a landslide, and the
break in at the Watergate complex seemed almost
like a footnote to the campaign.
And it might have remained there, except for
two young Washington Post reporters, Bob Woodward
and Carl Bernstein.
They pursued lead after lead, revealing in
one instance that Attorney General John Mitchell
had a secret fund that was used to spy on
democratic officials.
The Nixon administration charged that their
reporting was biased and baseless, and they
pressured the Post publisher, Katharine Graham,
and the Post editor, Ben Bradlee, to call
off the two young reporters.
Graham and Bradley refused, but they had their
doubts.
If what Woodward and Bernstein was reporting
was so accurate and so important, why were
other news organizations not following up
on the story?
Eventually the Post reporting convinced Congress
that there was something to this story and
Congress began its investigation that in the
end led to the resignation of President Richard
Nixon.
The Post Watergate coverage illustrates the
press at its best, pursuing its watchdog role
under the First Amendment, carrying out its
duty to keep an eye on those in power, and
to reporting when they engage in wrongdoing.